queen elizabeth is making some changes
to an annual ceremony
my lord's prayer was issued
on tuesday the queen opened up the
british parliament but there wasn't a
big celebration like usual
the 95 year old reigning monarch decided
to scale back the event this year
traveling to the house of parliament in
a car and not a carriage
[Music]
the queen also chose not to wear a crown
or a formal gown for the occasion
opting for a floral dress with a
matching lilac coat embroidered with
yellow flowers at the collar
and a matching hat there was also no
military band or guard of honor to
participate in the procession from
buckingham palace to the palace of
westminster
another big change the consorts throne
formerly belonging to the queen's late
husband prince philip
was removed leaving queen elizabeth's
throne to stand alone
prince philip accompanied elizabeth to
the event for decades until his
retirement in 2017.
last month the duke of edinburgh who
died at 99 years old was laid to rest at
st
george's church chapel
the ceremony marked her first outing
since his funeral service
but not the first milestone she
celebrated without philip
in april the queen celebrated her 95th
birthday with the royal family
at the time royal expert katie nicholl
told et how her majesty was feeling
ahead of her special day
well it is indeed a very somber birthday
for the queen of course the first
birthday that she will have spent
in 73 years without the duke of
edinburgh by her
side so a lonely birthday but she has
not been completely
on her own we understand that she has
been visited by some family members
today
the queen has two birthdays she has her
actual birthday which is today the 21st
of april
and then she has her official birthday
celebrations
in june which everyone will recognize as
truthing the color
so the birthday in april is always a
pretty low-key affair
today is always a relatively quiet day
a low-key day but of course today is
all the harder for not having philip by
her side